what i want to do in this video is start
with the abstract i guess you could call
it formula for the chain rule and then
learn to apply it in the concrete
setting
so let's start off with some function
some expression that can be expressed as
the product of two func or the comp the
composition of two functions so it can
be expressed as
f
of g of x
f of g of x
so it's a function that can be expressed
as a composition or expression that can
be expressed as the composition of two
functions
let me get that same that same color i
want the colors to be accurate and my
goal is to take the derivative of this
business the derivative with respect to
x
and what the chain rule tells us is that
this is going to be equal to the
derivative of the outer function with
respect to the inner function and we can
write that as f prime of not x but f
prime of g of x of the inner function f
prime of g of x
times
the derivative of the inner function
with respect to x
the derivative of the inner function
with respect to x now this might seem
all very abstract and mathy how do you
actually apply it well let's try it with
a real example let's say we were trying
to take the derivative
let's say we're trying to take the
derivative
of
of the square root
the square root
of 3x squared
3x squared
minus x so how could we define an f and
a g so that this really is the
composition of f of x and g of x
well we could define f of x if we
defined f of x as being equal to the
square root of x
and if we defined g of x
g of x as being equaling as being equal
to 3 x squared
minus x then what is f of g of x
well f f of g of x is going to be equal
to i'm going to try to keep all the
colors accurate hopefully it helps the
understanding
f of g of x is equal to where everywhere
you see the x you're replaced with the g
of x the principal root of g of x
of g of x
which is equal to
which is equal to the principal root of
we've defined g of x right over here 3x
squared minus x
of 3
x squared minus x so this thing right
over here is exactly f of g of x if we
define f of x in this way and g of x in
this way
fair enough so let's apply the chain
rule
what is
what is f prime of g of x going to be
equal to the derivative of f with
respect to g
well what's f prime of x
f prime of x is equal to this is the
same thing as x to the one-half power so
we can just apply the power rule so it's
going to be one-half
times x to the and then we just take one
away from the exponent one-half minus
one is negative
one-half
and so what is f prime
of g of x
f prime of
g of x
well wherever we're in the derivative we
saw in x we can replace it with the g of
x it's going to be one-half
times instead of an x to the negative
one-half we can write a g of x
we can write a g of x to the one-half
and this is just going to be equal to
this is just going to be equal to let me
write it right over here it's going to
be equal to one-half
one-half times all of this business to
the negative one-half power
so 3x squared 3x squared minus x which
is exactly so which is exactly what we
need to solve right over here f prime of
g of x f prime of g of x is equal to
this
so
this part right over here i will let me
square it off in green
what i'm what we're trying to solve
right over here f prime of g of x we've
just figured out is exactly
this thing
right over here it's the derivative of f
of the outer function with respect to
the inner function
so let me write it it is equal to
one-half
times
g of x to the negative one half
times three x squared
minus x
this is exactly this based on how we've
defined f of x and how we've defined g
of x conceptually if you're just looking
at this the derivative of the outer
thing you're taking something to the
one-half power so the derivative of that
whole thing with respect to your
something is going to be one-half times
that something to the negative one-half
power that's essentially what we're
saying but now we have to take the
derivative of our something with respect
to x the derivative of our something
with respect to x
and that's more straightforward g prime
of x we just use the power rule for each
of these terms is equal to 6 x to the
first or just 6x
minus 1. so this part right over here is
just going to be 6x
minus 1. just to be clear this
right over here
is this
right over here and we're multiplying
and we're done we have just applied the
power rule so just to review it's the
derivative of the outer function with
respect to the inner so instead of
having one-half x to the negative
one-half it's one-half g of x to the
negative one-half times the derivative
of the inner function with respect to x
times the derivative of g with respect
to x which is right over there